at this point
the foot is going to turn fast but it's
going to move there as well
so I go just transfer my weight and it
moves there
is
just there
right
foreign
find your balance
this is on your head this is kihon
the whole thing would be
hey
this is the whole thing
if you want to go into the whole thing
that's okay as long as you get the first
part
[Music]
okay
your partner's doing sure Nagi
oh sometimes for me to go this is if
you've got to remember
those who aren't taking new chemi only
get to this piece
so yep you you're doing this
and then
it's as if you know something's up there
or you're you're waiting for the
technique to happen Okay this shouldn't
be happening I should be hey
I should be uh occupying their mind by
ah that movement taking him this way
he has to have an occupied mind
hi Tammy
that means that he's already busy I take
here and this one comes up here this
keeps him occupied
okay so please
power Coke you
like this look we're going we're going
this way and I'm going to take him
whether he wants it or not
so at first you redirect their power hey
and then you do something with it
okay try out with you Cami
you need to put your key eyes
let me
hey
you're making it hard work
it's your hips
would do the error
try to watch closely
eight eight
just here slowly down slowly down
all you do is you get worn out and I
love who cameras and you don't learn the
form
all right
try to keep your hands in front of you
all the time
your hands in front of you all the time
right
to your hands
in front of you all the time
a nice Mouse
you've got it and it feels fine
that's no good it should never be
feeling good
to the point that you're not searching
so you always search for your techniques
watch my front hand I'll do different
angles great I'll bring it in front of
my Center
I'd tell me I sweep it down
this way
I sweep it down now this way this is the
Fairing and the feeling as I turn I'm
going to keep looking at his hand all
the way
this is the feeling
I'll do it this time
okay
I do this
so what causes you to have problems
he holds strong
when you go to them this is when you
have problems when you go now to them
and you get your hand lost you try to
pull it forward but it won't go so you
end up leaning back and then you regain
yourself and then you're okay you're in
command
the problem is that you haven't got a
flexible enough mind you're flexible
enough body but your mind is stuck
it's got to do that but if you do that
Common Sense tells you he'll take his
hand off
so you're left with nothing
so you need to secure the hand that's
grabbed you
so you hold take your hand off
now you don't have a problem
so these are all secured
you're going to turn this together
you now take up
you then keep looking at your hands
to save you dipping backwards you bring
your hips
through
so you fold yourself
just this is a difficult point to
understand
one two
who draw him through
about here you've got to try and get
round
you'd now bring your sorry you now bring
your hips through
that's that's how you keep your hands in
front of your head
done what let's try it try and think of